how is u.s being bullied by china right
now
on many fronts so if you want to get
into the broad picture of it
the say the type of real bullying if you
were to ask me
that's when you get into things like
economic theft you get into things like
culture you get into things like drugs
um you know again what they call
unrestricted warfare
and it's based on you know this is
actually name of a book it's a lot of
china experts talk about it
as being kind of the uh the basic
framework through which china has waged
an unconventional war on the united
states
so 1999 two chinese colonels wrote a
book called unrestricted warfare where
they proposed a new system of war
without morals and it's based on a very
simple way of thinking now if you want
to get into the
you know nitty gritty the gist of it we
could go on forever talking about
all the different forms of
unconventional war they run
you know names all across the board
everything you could think of being
targeted
but it comes down to this it's a
perception of saying
what would you want to achieve through
warfare
and how can you achieve those exact same
goals
without engaging in open combat and so
for example
culture warfare you know china's of
course gained significant control over
hollywood
not just through say manipulation say
forcing them to abide by chinese laws
when it comes to censorship and
propaganda
if they want to get their films into
china which is a huge market for
hollywood
especially right now when you know films
aren't doing as hot
to you know for example buying up in
buying up
parts of ownership and say production
houses talent houses
buying amc theaters for example these
types of things
you know they can then control what is
shown in our movies
for example they can't if they want to
get to china they can't show china in a
negative light
they can't show the us military in a
positive light if they want to get into
china
they need to maintain say you know at
least one
scene in china they have to have at
least one chinese actor or actress and
so on
certain requirements for that and of
course the chinese regime xi jinping
actually back when they
launched a lot of these operations came
out and said the united states is
launching a culture war on china
and said that they needed to retaliate
they talk about this stuff openly
when it comes to drug warfare for
example how do you destroy the
the moral fabric of a society we talk
about things like these uh synthetic
drugs fentanyl
that comes from china but what's
actually not really as well known is
that most of our drugs come from china
the drug cartels in latin america they
get their precursor chemicals from china
in fact there have been some reports
saying that they're having trouble
manufacturing because a lot of their
labs they were getting their precursor
chemicals from for things like
methamphetamine and other drugs
were coming from wuhan the epicenter of
this virus
and so you know you name it across the
board this is how this is the real way
they're bullying america
you